[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrait à la flambée des prix dans le
monde vous l'avez constaté les prix des
hydrocarbures mais aussi les prix
alimentaires explose accentuée par la
guerre en ukraine aux etats unis
l'inflation au mois de mars atteint un
record et oblige joe biden a modifié sa
politique économique certains pays
émergents connaissent déjà des pénuries
alimentaires qui menace aussi l'europe
en france augmentation des prix à la
consommation depuis un an et de 5,1 pour
cent la moitié s'est produite sur les
deux derniers mois jamais les français
n'ont encaissé un tel choc depuis 50 ans
le pouvoir d'achat leur première
préoccupation est au coeur du second
tour de cette campagne présidentielle
alors la flambée des prix jusqu'où
comment y faire face en france que
proposé deux candidats pour le pouvoir
d'achat on posera la question à mes
invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
benjamin coriat bonsoir dans son
vestiaire émérite de sciences
économiques à la sorbonne paris nord
membre des économistes atterrés hauteur
de le bien commun le climat et le marché
et c'est aux liens qui libèrent
bienvenue à vous benjamin coriat elie
cohen est avec nous économiste et
directeur de recherche émérite au cnrs
votre ouvrage la valse européenne les
trois temps de la crise et aux éditions
fayard bonsoir elie cohen et bien ce
soir l'idri faillite avec nous
chroniqueuse économique à france24
bonsoir line cet effet nous allons
également à voir dans la première partie
de cette émission mathieu mabin notre
correspondant à washington et avant de
vous entendre et bien on va démarrer par
l'inflation justement aux états unis qui
met en péril la popularité de joe biden
line rifaï tout de suite je me tourne
vers vous on va regarder cette dls avec
vous une inflation aux etats unis qui
est de 8 5% en rythme annuel contre 7,9
pour cent le mois dernier ça n'arrête
pas de grimper on peut dire que la
contribution l'énergie et massive dans
ce chiffre c'est vrai c'est fini ça fait
un an à peu près que l'inflation et au
delà des 2 % l'objectif de la banque
centrale américaine mais ça fait
quelques mois que tout cela s'accélère
et encore plus depuis le début de la
guerre en ukraine on voit ici les
chiffres les derniers chiffres qui
viennent de paraître pour le mois de
mars une inflation à huit et demi
pourcent toutes catégories donc si
l'inflation moyenne pour les états unis
et ce qui cause en particulier cette
inflation c'est la flambée des prix de
l'énergie vous le voyez +30 2% pour les
prix de l'énergie en rythme annuel
tandis rire au carbure les hydrocarbures
les toutes sortes d'énergies donc ils
rentrent le gaz les keufs enfin le
pétrole et c est donc qu cette flambée
des prix mais il n'ya pas que la hausse
des prix de l'énergie qui cause cette
inflation c'est la raison principale
mais il ya aussi et vous en avez parlé
la hausse des prix des aliments avec la
guerre en ukraine mais même avant la
ville hausse des prix des céréales il y
avait les sécheresses et ensuite les
difficultés d'approvisionnement liées à
la gare en ukraine prend un des
principaux pourvoyeurs un des principaux
exportateurs de blé donc si on regarde
encore ces chiffres 8 8% de hausse pour
les prix de l'alimentation et puis il ne
faut pas oublier les salaires les
salaires qui augmentent aux états unis
on est sur un marché du travail très
tendu un taux de chômage à 3,6 pour cent
de la population active seulement on a
vu aussi ces derniers mois le mouvement
de vastes démission aux états unis donc
pour attirer les meilleurs salariés vous
pour atteindre tout simplement les
salariés les entreprises doivent
augmenter les salaires mathieu mahb à
washington cette hausse des prix mathieu
à ce qu'elles pèsent sur la popularité
de joe biden on a tout de même
l'impression qu'elles pèsent sur sa
propre à la popularité à quelques mois
des meters de ces fameuses élections
mi-mandat
oui indiscutablement on a entendu
l'hymne à l'instant évoqué ce taux
d'inflation record aux états unis et
cette lente escalade des prix qui
impacte il faut le dire directement la
vie des américains sur l'ensemble des
produits de consommation courante il y a
deux indicateurs auquel les
consommateurs américains sont
particulièrement sensibles et qui
transforme le niveau de l'inflation en
quelque chose de très concret pour eux
c'est d'une part le prix du chariot de
courses au supermarché tout simplement
mais également le prix du gallon à la
pompe en clair le prix du carburant dans
un pays où la mobilité routière comme on
le sait ne connaît quasiment aucune
alternative alors bien sûr les citoyens
américains sont parfaitement capables de
comprendre que cette hausse des prix
n'est pas directement le fait de
l'administration en place mais ça
n'empêche pas ça n'empêche que joe biden
sera effectivement jugé sur sa capacité
au moins atténuer d'une part les effets
de la guerre en ukraine sur l'économie m
week-end et d'autre part sur sa capacité
on l'a dit à compenser cette inflation
or pour le moment les consommateurs
américains sont convaincus d'une chose
et je dirai quelle que soit leur
sensibilité démocrate ou républicaine
joe biden jusqu'à présent était
techniquement incapable d'endiguer la
hausse des prix qui sur un chariot de
100 $ par exemple voient le budget
alimentaire des familles augmenté de
bientôt une dizaine de dollars ce qui
est considérable mais plus marquant
encore on l'a dit le prix des carburants
à la pompe qui atteint désormais 4
dollars 10 et 44 dollar 10 et 4 $ fin
quand on interroge les consommateurs
américains ils nous expliquent qu'ils
peuvent compenser l'inflation par une
baisse de leur consommation y compris
alimentaires mais ce qui à terme aura un
effet dévastateur sur la pologne
popularité de l'administration by day
c'est ce rendez vous hebdomadaire à la
station service qui rappelle aux
électeurs américains que leur pouvoir
d'achat est en chute libre elie cohen
est ce que c'est inquiétant est ce que
finalement ça nous rappelle d'autres
souvenirs par exemple 2008 ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui
annoncé il faut remonter au delà de 2008
ce qui est en train de se passer est
tout à fait exceptionnel je crois que il
ya un chiffre qui - résume pour moi la
faire sur l'année écoulée le prix du gaz
a été multiplié par dix ne s'est pas une
augmentation de 10 20 30 40 ou 50 % a
été multiplié par dix on n'a jamais vu
ça et ça c'est la guerre en ukraine
alors ça c'est l'accumulation c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est l'accumulation
de plusieurs phénomènes premier
phénomène ça a été le co vide et puis la
première vague du coc vide et puis après
il ya eu la relance et la relance trump
et la relance biden et puis après il ya
eu les perturbations dans les flux
logistiques internationaux et puis il ya
eu la nouvelle vague qu'ovide et puis
après il ya eu l'ukraine et les
problèmes avec la russie donc si vous
voulez c'est un véritable mille feuilles
de phénomènes de déstabilisation qui se
sont cumulées ce qui fait qu'au départ
on continue à faire les minions nous
autres économistes en disant il faut
distinguer l'inflation de base de
l'inflation exceptionnelles combles
d'appel l'accord in flight sean et on va
essayer des purées lundi prix des
phénomènes perturbateurs comme l'énergie
ou l'alimentaire et puis en fait on a vu
que l'énergie et l'alimentaire sont
devenus le principal moteur de cette
inflation alors dans un deuxième temps
on a dit oui mais ce qui est rassurant
c'est qu'on n'a pas une véritable
inflation parce que la véritable
inflation c'est quand vous avez la
boucle prix salaires c'est-à-dire quand
la hausse des prix continue fini par
déclencher une hausse de salaire et que
la hausse devient auto entretenue et
comme ça a été dit diane spirale c'est
ce qu'on a observé aux états unis alors
après on a dit mais ce qui se passe aux
etats unis est très différente qui se
passe en europe et en fait ce qu'on voit
c'est que il ya une convergence
progressive à la fois vers une hausse
cumulative des prix vers la formation de
phénomène de spirale prix salaires et
par le fait que plus personne ne
maîtrise les marchés de matières
premières les marchés de l'énergie et
les marchés alimentaires et jama coriace
et inquiétant elle t'a vous décrit par
elie cohen en tout cas vous êtes tous
d'accord on est dans une espèce de
spirale inflationniste mondial oui avant
de venir à la spirale inflationniste et
pour aller tout à fait dans le même sens
de que ce que disait elie
je rajoute un mot
qui est implicite mais qui est très
important à quoi on assiste en assiste à
ce que nous les économistes dans le
jargon on appelle la rupture des chaînes
de valeur mais en réalité ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire au fait que des
économies nos économies sont totalement
mondialisé que les circuits sont
totalement internationaux et que ces
chocs successifs
les différentes vagues de qu'ovide plus
la guerre en ukraine ont rompu ses
chaînes d'approvisionnement donc c'est
une inflation qui a pas vraiment rien à
voir avec enfin une crise qui a rien à
voir avec celle de avec celle de 2008
parce que là on a c'est plus profond
d'une certaine manière et on sent toute
la vulnérabilité du système sur lesquels
sur lequel on est assis qui se marquent
notamment dans les prix du gaz mais
comme on l'avait senti à l'époque du
covin sur le fait que les médecins des
infirmiers avait pas de masque dont il y
avait une rupture complète vous parler
de la dépendance en fait de la tâche
avant je parle oui je parle de
l'interdépendance je parle du fait que
nos économies sont entièrement
mondialisée en tout cas pour ce qui nous
concerne nous en europe et que ces chocs
successifs ont cassé les chaînes
d'approvisionnement prix des hausses de
prix auquel on assiste c'est de la
rareté absolue des biens disponibles
du côté on n'arrive pas soit les
produits soient les transférer donc
c'est un phénomène très original du côté
des prix alimentaires dans un certain
nombre de pays émergents il y a déjà des
pénuries d pénurie de pain par exemple
dans un certain nombre de pays on va
écouter la directrice de l' omc ngozi
okonjo iweala
l'effet économique le plus immédiat de
la guerre a été une forte hausse des
prix des denrées alimentaires de
l'énergie des engrais et de certains
minéraux importants dont l'ukraine et la
russie sont les principaux fournisseurs
sur le marché mondial une crise
alimentaire potentiel est imminente les
prix des denrées alimentaires et de
l'énergie étaient déjà élevés par
rapport aux normes historiques avant la
guerre
laureline les nations unies donne
l'alerté oui parle de pays très
vulnérables de famine famine il famille
le mot est utilisé pour certains pays et
on va y revenir ya d'abord eu cet indice
publié vendredi par la ffa au donc
l'organisation des nations unies pour
l'alimentation et qui montre qu'on a
atteint un niveau jamais vu précédemment
subi pour la l'augmentation des prix
alimentaires +12 6% sur un mois c'est
juste une moyenne qui cache de
nombreuses disparités et cela donc
fait que certains pays font face à des
pénuries d'une nulle part parce qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens de payer si cher
pour s'approvisionner et parce qu'il ya
aussi des manques sur les marchés
mondiaux certains pays en développement
notamment dans la région moyen-orient et
en afrique sont très dépendants des
importations de blé d'ukraine de russie
un exemple celui du libre une économie
déjà en forte crise économique et
financière qui manque de devises pour
pouvoir importer et qui se retrouve donc
face à des difficultés
d'approvisionnement pas assez d'argent
pour acheter en blé de plus en plus
fiables et qui n'est plus disponible il
ya eu aussi l'explosion du port de
beyrouth qui fait qu'on peut plus
stockées dans les six du port de
beyrouth toutes ces quantités de blé une
crise avec aujourd'hui même une
fermeture de nombreuses boulangeries
pour montrer qu'on n'a plus assez de blé
pour produire du pain deux autres payé
très rapidement que je cite l'exemple du
yémen puisque les nations unies l'onu a
dit que ce pays allaient avoir besoin
d'assistance alimentaire au cours du
deuxième semestre 2022 et puis l'exemple
de la somalie au près de 40% de la
population fait face à des niveaux
extrêmes insécurité alimentaire et
certaines zones connaîtrait aussi
probablement déjà la famille toujours
selon les nations unies elie cohen donc
famine là c'est vrai que le tableau et
je dirais très compliqué on est
effectivement une situation inédite
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
si vous voulez quand vous constatez que
les deux pays qui étaient les plus gros
exportateurs de céréales mais aussi
d'huile de tournesol etc qu'était la
russie et surtout l'ukraine s'arrête et
de produire on a tous vu ces scènes où
les chansons labouré par des missiles
qui sont tombés et on a tous vu les
ports de la mer noire qui sont
totalement bloqués donc quand vous ne
pouvez plus produire et quand vous ne
pouvez plus exporter les pénuries
physique se manifeste ce manifeste
comment d'abord par des hausses de prix
alors vous avez donné des chiffres je
j'ose dire s'il n'y avait que 12 % de
hausse on s'enrichit on s'en réjouirait
presque non la variation du prix des
céréales ça ça là aussi c'est comme pour
le gaz sah atteignaient parfois plus 100
% plus de 100 % etc donc il ya ce
phénomène de pénurie physique et donc
effectivement des pays qui ont de plus
en plus de difficultés à pouvoir acheter
les le blé dont ils ont besoin et de
pouvoir donc simplement consommer et
satisfaire leurs populations et donc on
va avoir des émeutes de la faim ça on a
connu déjà ce genre de situation c'est à
dire des peuples livrés à eux mêmes
qu'ils n'ont plus la fourniture de base
avec des des intrants qui coûte de plus
en plus cher qui du coup vont donner une
deuxième vague de hausses de prix parce
que maintenant désagréments dus aux
agriculteurs dans la hâte notamment au
niveau européen se met davantage mais il
faut que disait le poids il puisse payer
les intrants c'est à dire les engrais
les produits chimiques l'énergie qui
elle entre temps aura beaucoup beaucoup
augmenter donc là aussi ça crée une
difficulté supplémentaire et ça nourrit
la vague suivante
mais benjamin tout à fait raison le vrai
vrai problème c'est la désorganisation
des chaînes de production et de
transport mondial et la découverte de
notre incroyable dépendance par rapport
à tel ou tel élément qu'avant on
estimait acquis dans le cadre de
l'économie de flux tendu qui organisait
la planète donc on est en fait en train
de découvrir cette interdépendance
benjamin coriat yagour surtout
stupéfaction générale oui on découvre à
faire on découvre on la redécouvre
asséché des oui disons qu'on découvre la
profondeur des conséquences si jamais il
ya le moindre accroc sur les questions
d'alimentation
il faut quand même dire parce que ça
c'est peu c'est peu dire que en temps
normal quand tout va bien il ya 900
millions de gens sur la planète qui sont
sous nutris ou malnutries bien donc on
était déjà dans une situation qui
n'était absolument pas bonne est pas
acceptable avec ce qu'on produit
aujourd'hui dans le monde à voir cette
situation là était déjà commandé un
arrière-fond extrêmement
compliqué
vous rajoutez à ça les phénomènes de
désorganisation et il faut bien dire
parce que ça a été le cas par exemple
sur les vaccins le l'égoïsme des nations
1 c'est-à-dire la rue et 1,2 des plus
nantis pour assurer des stocks
permettant donc d'une certaine manière
on peut le comprendre mais en tout cas
c'est ça qu'on a vu ce qu'on appelait le
nationalisme vaccinale ben maintenant on
a dû du nationalisme alimentaire on a
des pays qui peuvent payer les prix
impossible
qui sont sur le marché et qui
accroissent encore l'impossibilité pour
les plus pauvres de s'alimenter donc oui
on va arriver vers des situations
absolument dramatique mathieu à
washington les états unis est ce qu ils
peuvent compenser un certain nombre de
pénurie alimentaire
alors on l'a déjà formulé partiellement
mais les états unis n'échappent pas aux
effets de la crise alimentaire qui
s'annonce et de la paralysie des
greniers à grains russes ukrainiens et
même biélorusse alors bien sûr les
américains ne risque pas la famine comme
dans d'autres parties du monde
évidemment mais pour eux aussi le coût
de l'alimentation pourrait grimper
jusqu'à 10 % ce sont les pronostics et
cela indépendamment de l'inflation qu'on
a évoqué un instant mais ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que techniquement les
états unis possèdent une agriculture qui
pourrait justement compenser les baisses
de production russe et ukrainienne mais
pour cela il faudrait réformer en
profondeur la politique agricole
américaine et l'a réorientée vers la
production céréale qu'elle n'a pas
complètement abandonné évidemment mais
qui a été au moins partiellement
délaissé ces dernières années au profit
de la culture du soja notamment moins de
blé moins de maïs plus de chasser le
choix qui a été fait par les
agriculteurs américains ces dernières
années justement parce qu'il ne
parvenait plus à concurrencer les
céréaliers d'europe de l'est c'est tout
le paradoxe mais vous imaginez bien on
parle ici d'agriculture et que pour
réformer dans ces proportions un outil
de production à l'échelle d'un pays
comme les etats-unis il faut beaucoup
plus qu'une saison et il est donc
illusoire au moment où nous parlons
d'imaginer que l'amérique sauvera le
monde de la crise alimentaire
c'est la même situation en europe la
logique majeur des politiques
européennes depuis au moins une décennie
c'est de mettre en jachère une partie
des terres parce qu'on produisait trop
et parce qu'on pensait que
l'exploitation des sols ne correspondait
pas aux standards écologiques donc on a
mis en jachère et maintenant en
catastrophe on est en train d'inciter
les agriculteurs à remettre en
exploitation des terres que qu'on avait
mise en jachère y encore quelques mois
c'est un peu panique à bord c'est aussi
un peu panique à bord parce que moi je
me réjouis pas de ce volte face qu'on
fait sur les questions à
alimentaire parce que bien sûr il faut
faire face mais en même temps si ça ça
doit signifier un recul sur les
questions écologiques comme c'est le cas
d'ailleurs à propos de l'énergie ou
maintenant on remet en exploitation des
champs d'hydrocarbures alors que le giec
la semaine dernière nous a dit on a
trois ans pour commencer à inverser la
courbe bon donc je veux dire ça vient
encore aggraver le tableau un faux pas
faux pas je veux dire le peu qui a été
fait dans la mise en sachet n'était pas
une politique erronée ce qui est ce qui
est ce qui va passer le cadre dans
lequel on est mais il faut surtout pas
que d'écologie soins la victime de la
crise actuelle surtout pas en france en
tout cas on voit bien pouvoir d'achat
est la première préoccupation des
français l'inflation et de 5,1 pour cent
et la moitié de cette augmentation des
prix en france s'est produite sur les
deux derniers mois c'est-à-dire au mois
de février au mois de mars jamais
manifestement les français n'avaient
encaissé un tel choc depuis 50 ans on va
faire le point en images avec nos
confrères de france 2 et on en parle
ensuite
dans les rayons des prix qui augmentent
et dans l'esprit des français est une
préoccupation leur pouvoir d'achat à
lyon dans cette grande surface l'idée
d'un chèque alimentaire promesse d'
emmanuel macron divise ses consommateurs
c'est très bien notamment pour les
populations les plus fragiles à très
court terme une suppression de ce soit
viable oui ça peut toujours aider mais
est-ce que c'est suffisant
de son côté marine le pen souhaite
lancer un panier de produits de première
nécessité sans aucune tva certains
clients restent sceptiques
c'est ça se faisait rouer taxer un peu
plus les salaires
à la station service les prix ont aussi
flambé ces derniers mois alors pour
faire face à l'ensemble des
augmentations emmanuel macron en tant
que président a mis en place une
indemnité inflation de sang seront
versés en début d'année autre mesure 18
centimes de remise par litre de
carburant jusqu'à la fin du mois de
juillet prolonger c est depuis longtemps
une promesse du candidat
indispensable pour ces automobilistes
c'est c'est très intéressant ça aide
énormément par son entreprise bond dans
le temps de projeter des jets qui vous
rendent pas un truc pour amener sur le
court pour faire baisser le plein
d'essence la candidate du rassemblement
national elle promet des baisses de
taxes sur les carburants seule mesure
vraiment efficace pour certains un peu
moins
donc on s'est retrouvés nous
l'état fassent des efforts aussi deux
projets deux candidats qui compte bien
mettre le pouvoir d'achat au coeur de la
campagne de l'entre-deux tours et on va
passer au crible bien sûr les
propositions de marine le pen d'un côté
et d'emmanuel macron de l'autre mais
avant ça on va d'abord faire les
chiffres avec linlin rifaï augmentation
des prix à la consommation en france
depuis un an de 5,1 pour cent et c'est
beaucoup oui alors il ya deux chiffres
us pour le préciser qui circulent pour
l'inflation en france 4 et demi pourcent
qu'est le chiffre de l'insee et 5,1 pour
cent ces chiffres qu'on a choisi
d'utiliser parce que c'est le chiffre 2
stade qui nous permet de faire des
comparaisons européennes c'est un
chiffre qui prend davantage en compte
les produits énergétiques on le verra
tout à l'heure vous voyez ici en france
par rapport aux autres pays européens la
france on pourrait dire qu'elle ne se
place pas si mal malgré une inflation
record jamais vu depuis que recettes
calculs ces chiffres 5,1 % d'inflation
c'est en dessous de la moyenne de la
zone euro qui a sept et demi pour cent
c'est bien en deçà d'un pays comme
l'espagne par exemple avec une inflation
qui frôle les 10% alors pourquoi cette
inflation en france est plus faible que
la moyenne européenne même si la très
élevée on l'a dit jamais vu en france
depuis des décennies d'abord parce que
il ya une composante importante de cette
inflation qui vient de l'énergie on voit
ici si on prend toutes les catégories il
ya une augmentation au niveau européen
en tout cas de 44 7 % de l'énergie en
france avec des mesures pour bloquer les
prix de l'électricité du gaz également
un mix énergétique avec une électricité
qui vient à 70% du nucléaire et puis
d'autres raisons aussi à cela des
salaires qui augmentent par exemple
moins vite qu'en allemagne qui font que
ça pourrait expliquer entre autres le
fait que les prix accélère moins vite
que dans d'autres pays de la zone euro
pourtant les consommateurs ressentent
très fort cette inflation parce qu'elles
touchent des produits du quotidien et
notamment les produits alimentaires
quand ils vont au supermarché évoque le
prix des pâtes augmente surtout n'est
pas le premier prix parce que la matière
première elle occupe une place
prépondérante dans le prix d'autres bien
également donc les consommateurs quand
on leur montre ce gir ils ont du mal à
relativiser elie cohen ils ont du mal à
relativiser les consommateurs on va leur
dire qu'effectivement la france se place
plutôt mieux que ses partenaires
européens mais aujourd'hui effectivement
le panier de la ménagère on peut dire il
prend et prend un sacré coup fait
surtout le phénomène le plus important
c'est que depuis quinze ans on se
battait pour atteindre l'objectif d'une
hausse des prix de 2 % puisque la
politique de la banque centrale étaient
calées sur cet objectif de hausse des
prix de 2% et on était régulièrement en
dessous des 2% à tel point qu'on se
demander si nos outils de politique
monétaire étaient bien adaptées et puis
d'un seul coup d'un seul en un an ont
franchi ce seuil de 2% et alors ce qui
est encore plus intéressant c'est qu'on
voit que dans la distribution des
hausses de prix un pays comme l'espagne
fait + 10 %
et nous français avec 5 % ont fait
partie de ces chanceux de ceux qui ont
te une hausse des prix relativement au
destin en un mot l'espagne et la france
pourquoi l'espagne atteint c'est un
record ah bah parce que l'espagne subit
plus durement que nous et la hausse des
prix de l'énergie parce qu'ils n'ont pas
le mix énergétique qui est le nôtre et
la hausse des prix alimentaires et les
effets de la désorganisation du commerce
bon donc alors aujourd'hui 11é mais est
ce que la banque centrale va inventer un
nouvel outil de politique monétaire pour
tenir compte de cette inflation alors
c'est là qu'intervient un autre problème
qui est que plus le temps passe et plus
on perd le souvenir d inflation qu'on a
connus par le passé en france moi je me
souviens pendant la campagne électorale
de de françois mitterrand en 81 bah on
avait à l'époque des hausses de prix qui
était de l'ordre de 14% et ça a été ça
ensuite eu des années 80 on avait ça où
on avait 14 ans est monté à 13 7 oui
voilà et puis alors et après le grand
débat c'est est est-ce qu'il fallait
qu'on des index les salaires sur les
prix parce que ce qu'on a fait
d'ailleurs parce que la spirale
inflationniste paraissait non maîtrisée
et il est très singulier de constater
qu'aujourd'hui en catastrophe on est en
train de réintégrer vous avez vu ce qui
a été promis pour la hausse du smic
pourquoi mais parce qu'il ya un autre
élément qu'il faut ajouter je veux juste
devant sir sur les 15 dernières années
la hausse du pouvoir d'achat en france
moyenne vous savez combien l'a été sur
les 15 dernières années 0 5% vers les
français sont habitués à une progression
et faibles de leur pouvoir d'achat
depuis 15 ans ils ont donc le sentiment
qu'ont tenu du fait qu'une partie des
dépenses sont des dépenses obligées et
que ses dépenses obligées notamment les
dépenses énergétiques de loyer etc
augmentent plus vite ils ont vraiment le
sentiment d'un appauvrissement relatif
donc on se trouve dans une situation où
il ya reprise de l'inflation sentiment
d'appauvrissement relatif conscience que
le pouvoir d'achat stagner au minimum au
cours des 15 dernières années et nos
hommes politiques qui sont en campagne
actuellement vont devoir répondre à tous
ces défis en même temps benjamin coriat
où il se ressentit très fort
effectivement pouvoir d'achat premier
premier souci des français
bah oui et à juste titre un à juste
titre parce que vous êtes d'accord avec
tout ce que vient de dire elie cohen du
majin oui oui c'est des choses qu'on
sait qu'elle n'y a pas il n'y a pas
grand chose à dire parce que c'est cd
c'est du factuel donc toujours des
chiens ont fait des liens ca reculer
pendant ces dix ans où il a stagné en a
il a cette année il a un tout petit peu
augmentation sur les 15 derniers
génèrent des les chiffes avant de venir
les 15 dernières années ' l'augmentation
était de 0,5 mais ce qui est important
c'est que sur les quinze ans j'ai
découvert ça pendant cinq ans le pouvoir
d'achat a baissé
ouais et il ya eu des effets de
rattrapage après nous en fait peut-être
une volonté d'indexer les salaires sur
les prix c'était ça la différence des
années 80 oui oui ben c'est à dire on
les avait des indexées ça a été le
tournant de la rigueur un en particulier
jacques delors reims et c'est lui qui a
lancé en 1988
la rigueur ce qu'on a fait le tour n'a
de rigueur bon qui a désindexé alors que
ça n'a pas eu d'effets trop
catastrophique d'un point de vue
macroéconomique parce que précisément on
a réussi progressivement à juguler
l'inflation et qu'on est resté en gros
sous des 2% mais dans une situation où
l'inflation repart et à grande vitesse
cette situation de désindexation peut
provoquer des largages si je peux dire
de secteurs entiers
de la population et du peuple d'où le
fait qu' il faut maintenant prendre des
mesures tout à fait sérieuse augmenter
les exemples comment oui certainement en
tout cas moi je n'ai aucun doute là
dessus je n'ai absolument aucun doute là
dessus c'est à dire que tout tools to le
bricolage qui a été fait pour soi disant
redonner du pouvoir d'achat à travers
finalement delà de la baisse de
prestations ou de la baisse d'impôt
local par exemple à pour la taxe
d'habitation qui a pris vie et qui a
privé des régions d'autant de ressources
pour moi ne sont pas des solutions c'est
à dire que ce qui est donné d'un côté et
repris de l'autre ça ne sert à rien
d'augmenter de 2 d'un point ou deux le
pouvoir d'achat réel si l'offre de
service public et si l'offre de
prestations sociales de son côté baisses
donc je suis en train de du tout de dire
que faut qu'on y'a qu'à un jeu les dit
tout à l'heure je pense que la situation
est complexe bien donc il faut à la fois
aller au feu sur la question de
l'énergie aie sur la question de
l'alimentation et il faut à la fois
penser à des modifications plus
profondes et c'est vrai que sur les
salaires compte tenu des niveaux
d'inégalités on a des marges en tout cas
pour les bas salaires vous êtes d'accord
non il faut il faut regarder les choses
de manière plus plus méthodique eux
est-ce qu'on pourrait décréter demain
une hausse générale des salaires banon
on butera très ranspach le bas salaires
1 non répondent jeudi des salaires
d'abord on butera très rapidement sur
une réalité qui est la réalité de la
faible compétitivité française qui se
traduit par ses déficits de balance
courante qui ne cesse d'augmenter et
c'est donc oui il faut inciter autant
que possible des entreprises qui le
peuvent à augmenter les salaires ça ses
premiers éléments le deuxième élément
c'est que je crois qu'il est juste de
prévoir une indexation quand même parce
que si on indexe pas notamment les bas
salaires et les bas revenus ça va se
traduire par un gâteau est d'accord avec
sur des lauriers à lomé indexation des
bas salaires assure la facilement on
n'avait sinon on va connaître des
baisses de pouvoir d'achat alors des
appâts vries brutale et d
appauvrissement cumulative avancées
proposées par les deux candidats parce
qu'effectivement on est en pleine
campagne le pouvoir d'achat donc sa
ville dans la campagne
alors grosso modo racontez-nous quelles
sont les propositions de marine le pen
et d' emmanuel macron va commencer par
marine le pen elle qui veut baisser
l'été la tva n'est ce pas oui les
produits énergétiques c'est une des
mesures qu'elle propose alors marine le
pen elle a mis le pouvoir d'achat au
coeur de sa campagne c'est vrai mais si
on regarde son programme sur internet
c'est à dire ses 22 propositions pour
2022 comme on est comme elle les appelle
le pouvoir d'achat les promesses sur le
pouvoir d'achat n'arrive qu'en quatrième
position derrière les questions
d'immigration d'islamisme et de sécurité
ensuite maintenant quand on regarde les
mesures qu'elle propose il ya en effet
la proposition de baisser la tva sur les
produits énergétiques de 20% à 5 et demi
pour cent cela signifie des recettes en
moins pour l'état il faudra voir comment
ça sera financée elle dit aussi vouloir
permettre aux entreprises des hausses de
salaire de 10% tout là haut c'est une
mesure incitative rien d'obligatoire là
dedans des incitations d'augmenter les
salaires de 10% pour les salaires qui
vont jusqu'à 3 smic à peu près 4500
euros bruts des augmentations de salaire
qui serait encouragé comment par des
exonérations de cotisations patronales
et puis elle veut aussi renationaliser
les autoroutes pour dit-elle faire
baisser les péages de 25% sas et
quelques-unes des propositions de marine
le pen regardons maintenant du côté des
manuels macron que propose-t-il pour le
pouvoir d'achat la question du pouvoir
d'achat ces invités très tôt à l'agenda
des manuels macron avant même son entrée
en campagne parce qu'avec des mesures
que vous avez cités effectivement qui
ont été prises par son gouvernement
comme la prime inflation comme le gel
des prix de l'électricité et donc à face
à cela il ya eu ces mesures ponctuelles
donc qu'on a cité le chèque énergie
aussi et puis en revanche dans son
programme l'expression pouvoir d'achat
elle n'est pas mise en avant il est
plutôt question je cite là de mieux
vivre de son travail alors que
propose-t-il trois propositions très
rapide d'abord le triplement de ce qu'on
appelle la prima crossing prime
défiscalisées qui allait jusqu'à 2000
euros si on la tripe on peut aller
jusqu'à 6000 euros donc là aussi on
encourage les entreprises à l'adversaire
ça va ça vient cette prime obligatoire
donc aux salariés donc des entreprises
qui peuvent le soleil voilà et il
souhaite aussi un dispositif donc de
partage des profits obliger les
entreprises qui font des dividendes à
partager les profits et enfin en cas de
réélection il souhaite baisser les
charges pour les indépendants alors elie
cohen et benjamin coriat on va repasser
en revenus alors d'abord cette
proposition de marine le pen de baisser
la tva sur les produits énergétiques et
sur d'ailleurs les produits me sens
qu'il ya 100 produits alimentaire
hygiène avec une tva à zéro c'est une
bonne mesure où pas elie cohen écoutez
chaque fois que vous entendez baisse des
charges baisses d'impôts il faut
demander ou baisse des charges de la
fiscalité il faut demander tout de suite
par quoi on remplace les revenus perdus
qui vont à lo financement de la
protection sociale
alors on peut dire qu'on va financer ces
baisses de charges qu'est ce qu'elle dit
par l'augmentation des impôts mais là
c'est un peu ça meurt que sapeur
camember celle du froid que ces éléments
le ratio des ordres alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait dans ce cas on dit c'est
l'état qui va combler mais que ça veut
dire l'état l'état ça veut dire que
l'état va accroître son déficit et donc
ça veut dire que l'état va accroître sa
dette ça veut dire qu'on va financer des
mesures pérennes de gains de pouvoir
d'achat par un accroissement de la dette
publique
il faut il faut être conscient de ça
donc c est ce qu'au niveau à vous
écouter parce qu'au niveau actuel de
dette publique on peut encore ajouter
plusieurs couches supplémentaires de
dette publique non pas pour financer des
investissements non pas pour financer de
la recherche non pas pour financer la
croissance de demain mais pour donner
aux gens de quoi remplir le leur
leurs bidons d'essence ou de quoi
s'amuser dans les instruments pour vous
donc cette baisse de la tva benjamin
benjamin coriat écoutez propositions on
peut théoriquement souscrire à ce que
dit elie cohen mais je veux dire on fait
quoi on fait quoi 1 mais déjà elle est
souvent annoncé sur la
figure je suis un fanatique de la baisse
de la tva parce que une fois que
un impôt quelconque a disparu il revient
plus jamais et comme vous l'avez compris
je pense que on est comme la crise l'a
montré on a besoin d'un état qui a une
capacité d'affaires d'intervention pour
faire face aux crises donc on a besoin
d'avoir des ressources pérennes
indépendamment de l'endettement alors
donc baisse de la tva moi je suis plutôt
favorable à une mesure que les plus
anciens d'entre nous connaissent bien
qui était la mesure qui a été utilisé
pendant les premières hausses du prix du
pétrole qui était une taxe flottante sur
les carburants il n'y a aucune
ça veut dire que la taxe augmente ou
baisse en fonction du prix des
carburants alors ça al'avantage faire
davantage de permettre un abaissement
pour le consommateur et ça al'avantage
de faire en sorte que y'a pas cette
chose immorale qui est que l'état
bénéficient des hausses du prix de
l'énergie au détriment du consommateur
parce que lui prélève à taux fixe non
moi je serais pour une mesure de ce type
mais le fond le fond de la question
quand même c'est que il faut arriver 1
il n'y a pas 36 solutions
si on ne fait pas un transfert des hauts
revenus des patrimoines et c'est vers
les plus bas revenus on n'y arrivera pas
à voir si le silence de casino sinon
mais sinon on laisse crever les gens ou
bien catastrophe des catastrophes on
augmente la dette mais je veux dire
comment dire après le quoi qu'il en
coûte on va pas nous expliquer que on
peut plus toucher à rien je veux dire la
démonstration a été faite que quand il a
fallu déversé une pluie d'argent sur les
entreprises on l'a fait alors on passe
donc à emma dalmat je n'ai pas justement
s'est méchamment pas nous dire que ta
touche pas touche pas de noms mais je
vous signale que juste les mesures qui
ont été prises qui sont le chèque
énergie le chèque inflation etc ça fait
déjà 30 milliards d'euros me de dépenses
supplémentaires qui vont nourrir
directement il aimait citer la taille
ont l'inconvénient de ne rien toucher de
la wii hurel oui mais là on l'a fait
quand même remy
emmanuel macron parce qu'il faut et il
faut alors de 7,7 cette fameuse prime
elie cohen c'est une bonne idée x 3 la
prime mais non c'est la même chose c'est
la même critique c'est ça ce qui me
frappe c'est que même emmanuel macron
recours aux mêmes vieux instruments
usées qui consiste à dire on va baisser
les charges mais baisser les charges
c'est moins de ressources pour la
protection sociale moins de ressources
pour la protection sociale comme
personne n'envisage et c'est heureux de
diminuer la protection des français ça
veut dire que pour des dépenses maintenu
il va falloir de nouveau accroître le
déficit et accroître la dette donc dans
les instruments la prime oui non il ya
un accord il ya c'est un mauvais
instrument pour deux raisons pour deux
raisons la première c'est celle qui a
été dite c'est à dire que c'est des
primes défiscalisées donc ça revient au
fait que voilà on abaisse la capacité de
protection de l'état et d'intervention
de l'état suivant les cas et puis
deuxièmement c'est purement incitatif
c'est à dire c'est ce qu'ils veulent
pour les catégories de salariés qui
veulent alors que on est dans une
situation dans laquelle clairement il
faut cibler les bas revenus mais je veux
dire que je vais le dire comme ça il
faut venir au secours des bas revenus
donc y'a vraiment des mesures à prendre
et il faut mobiliser les salaires voit
sa demande et lui a demandé ce que vous
non mais c'est pour ça que je suis pour
une heureuse du spic j'insiste sur ce
point alors je suis ni l'un ni l'autre
n'ont
de propose à nous aimer ça sert si c'est
leur effet
déclaré qu'ils auraient
l'indexation mais j'anticipe et
normalement je les indexations du smic
ce fonds début janvier chaque année
macron annoncé que l'armée d'assurer dès
le mois de juin oui mais j'ai du style
comme par exemple avait pu proposer me
semble-t-il mais on vous le permettez je
vais dire pourquoi une hausse du smic
d'abord parce que c'est une mesure de
justice sociale élémentaire dans une
période d'inflation comme la nôtre mais
ensuite parce que le gros argument
consistant à dire ah là là ça rend la
france moins compétitives passez moi
l'expression c'est du baratin ça veut
dire que 80% des gens qui touchent le
smic ne sont pas exposés à la
concurrence internationale
c'est des cdc des gens qui travaillent
dans le commerce elle sinon t'as combien
etc aubin moi j'en sais rien mais je dis
ça dépend si le package qui compte mais
l'augmenter de 15% pour moi serait
absolument un minimum de réveil c'est
jean luc mélenchon des bruits dans la
façon melanchon mais plusieurs candidats
proposé d'augmenter le smic pour l'heure
jean luc mélenchon à 1400 euros nets
mais par rapport à tout ce qui est aussi
été dit par rapport à ces
défiscalisation ces baisses de
cotisations de charge il faut prendre
aussi en compte que si on augmente le
déficit et la dette on efface aussi un
état qui s'endettent à des taux de plus
en plus cher parce que façade soit
l'inflation et la banque centrale
européenne qui va sans doute avant la
fin de l'année relever ses taux
d'intérêt et déjà dès maintenant les
rendements des bons du trésor français
augmente alors bloquer les prix ce que
c'est une possibilité dit cohen ont
bloqué des prix jamais été une solution
franchement est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement ça veut dire quoi vous
allez bloquer le prix de l'essence à la
pompe par exemple et si le prix du
pétrole continue à augmenter si le prix
des produits raffinés continue à
augmenter qu'est ce que ça veut dire les
producteurs ne livreront plus les
distributeurs seront bloquées et on va
après inventé du rationnement dont
benjamin coriat propose des
augmentations du smic quel serait votre
proposition l'augmentation de belgique
mais oui j'ai commencé à leur dire qu'il
fallait il faire à d'accueil je
commençais d'exactions sa demande de
combien est bien là par les gaz passent
en compte tenu de la hausse des prix
importante qui a eu lieu il faudra
augmenter le smic à la prochaine
révision à due concurrence de la hausse
des prix s'est pas 15% ça c'est pas que
ça soit une hausse des prix c'est un
rattrapage c'est injuste rattrape bien
c'est un engagement mais moi je suis
pour une hausse au delà de l'inflation à
non en vrai nom est claire là dessus à
langer j'ai dit pourquoi mais à la fois
parce que c'est une terre de l'injustice
et les 26 que on a des montagnes de race
et de la flèche se fait par mon ami
gilbert cette et le président andré
mélisa de rien et qui montre bien valent
rien
l'un des effets mécaniques des hausses
continues du smic en france à la
différence d'autres pays c'est que le
salaire médian se rapproche de plus en
plus du smic et que donc qu'il n'ya plus
de carrière permise aux gens qui
rentrent dans le monde de l'entreprise
dans le monde de l'industrie et c'est
parce que la hausse du smic fait que ça
colle de plus en plus avec le salaire
médian
donc il n'ya pas de mobilité il n'ya pas
d'incitation à la formation et à la
qualification on a juste expliqué une
autre mesure éventuellement elie cohen
je serais d'accord avec benjamin pour
dire qu'il faut des mesures ciblées
prises pour les petits budgets pour les
petits consommateurs qui voient
effectivement leurs dépenses contraintes
donc plutôt des revenus c'est plutôt
prime ou plutôt baisse plutôt avenue tv
s'intéresser vos revenus pas de mesures
générales mais s'intéresser aux bas
revenus et avoir des mesures spécifiques
bas revenus benjamin
cdc c'est déjà ce que si je sais déjà ce
que j'ai dit mais moi ce que je pense
c'est que il ya deux séries de mesures
qu'il faut prendre il ya des mesures où
il faut aller au feu bon alors le le le
le blocage des prix je suis pas du tout
un fanatique du blocage des prix parce
que je pense que effectivement à long
terme ça n'est pas une solution mais
dans le court terme entre guillemets ça
peut être une solution en particulier
s'il s'agit de prix ciblées de toute
façon distribuer de l'argent par la
fenêtre sous la forme de primes
maquereau ou le blocage des plissés
pareil hein d'une certaine manière
val-senneville c'est tout aussi
artificielle c'est tout aussi
artificielle bon donc je dire je suis
absolument pas opposé à cette mesure à
titre transitoire la vraie question la
vraie question c'est un des changements
un tout petit peu structurelles sur la
manière dont les prix sont fixés par
exemple dans le domaine de l'énergie
comme vous le savez on est dans une
situation folle on est dans une
situation dans laquelle le prix de
l'énergie se fixe au prix de l'appareil
le moins efficace et le moins productif
d'europe bon c'était une situation
totalement faire dire expliqué en deux
minutes et ben c'est à dire que à
travers les conventions qui ont été
fixés concernant la fixation et
l'approvisionnement des prix en europe
le prix se fixe sur la dernière unité
qu'on met en fonction en europe à un
moment donné compte tenu de ce que de ce
qu'est la demande alors ça pouvait
justifier à une certaine époque mais là
plus du tout et des pays comme les
nôtres ou quoi qu'on pense du nucléaire
notre coût de production d'électricité
et du mix énergétique est beaucoup plus
bas qu'ailleurs on paye un prix
absolument disproportionné par rapport à
nos moyens donc je veux dire sur le
court moyen terme c'est à dire sur les
sur les deux ans qui viennent il faut
engager des réformes structurelles de ce
type pouvoir pour l'instant aucune des
deux propositions illico n ont plus rien
on a l'exemple que vient de donner
benjamin est très particulier c'est le
pré la fixation du prix de l'électricité
oui sur le marché devra pas le cahier de
la mairie de sortir de diriger européen
d'électricité c'est que 12 % de
l'énergie un c'est pas donc marine le
pen ressortir de ce marché des traces
étaient à l'arrière c'est vraiment
emmanuel macron non mais même je dirais
que non non non non notre ministre des
finances va bruxelles très régulièrement
il a demandé une renégociation des
modalités de fixation du prix de
l'électricité sur la plaque continentale
européenne intégrée bonne mesure dont tu
as quand on en rediscute oui on
rediscute oui parce que si vous voulez
avec le temps les mix énergétique des
différents pays européens ont beaucoup
diverger un pays comme la france qui est
un mix énergétique basée sur le
nucléaire à une beaucoup plus grande
stabilité prévisibilité des prix par
rapport à des pays comme l'italie ou
l'allemagne qui ont beaucoup misé sur le
gaz le gaz étant très très volatile et
donc quand vous dites que le prix du
marché de l'électricité c'est le prix de
l'unité qui est la dernière connecter
sur les réseaux c'est à dire celles dont
les prix sont les plus élevés elle va
vous produisez des phénomènes de hausse
des banques sa dette à revoir donc
emmanuel macron a priori serait il est
prêt à revoir se marie lebel aussi celle
absolument prêt mais donc mais nous
sommes pas seuls à bruxelles oui ça
passait là bas le problème est scellé
eux c'est que il ya toutes sortes de
promesses qui sont faites en période
électorale et malheureusement on est
quand même dans une situation dans
laquelle il ya aussi un bilan est donc
il ya une série de mesures sur
lesquelles et je suis annoncé sur lequel
je suis extrêmement sceptique non
seulement parce que c'est des mesures
totalement irréaliste sur le pouvoir
d'achat ou de râler des mesures en
particulier oui non mais sur l'ensemble
sur l'ensemble voyez par exemple je lise
et en venant là dans le taxi que que
emmanuel macron voulait faire une
convention citoyenne pour parler de
l'euthanasie ensuite trois médecins au
parlement
deux sociétés aient envie de dire non
mais j'ai envie de dire on a déjà donné
un maquereau et les conventions
citoyenne on sait ce que ça donne donc
si vous voulez parlons de choses
sérieuses et marine le pen sont ses
propositions économiques ah bin là pas
pris un soin extrême à conforter son
propos et puis surtout le programme
marine le pen appliquée c'est la sortie
de l'europe donc ça c'est un problème en
tout cas c'est ce que vous dites
il faut diminuer notre participation au
budget européen de manière unilatérale
réinstauré des contrôles douaniers aux
frontières intra communautaires
s'exonérer des responsabilités dans les
politiques qui ne nous conviennent pas
affirmer la prééminence du droit
français sur le droit européen si vous
additionnez tous à vous sortez de
l'europe merci beaucoup aidé quand même
d'avoir été avec no mercy benjamin
coriat merci les line rifai et puis
merci à mathieu mabin qui étaient avec
lui en première partie de l'émission en
direct de washington merci à vous tous
nous avons suivi et reste avec nous sans
fin 4
[Musique]